>> Greg: I'M GREG GUTFELD WITH
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
DANA PERINO.
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
AS STUDENTS PLAN GUN VIOLENCE
PROTESTS, LET'S BE HONEST.
NO ONE TRUSTS EACH OTHER IN THIS
DEBATE.
IF YOU SAY SENSIBLE GUN CONTROL,
OTHERS HEAR CODE FOR "YOU ARE
TAKING AWAY MY GUNS."
IF YOU SAY PROTECT MY GUN
RIGHTS, OTHERS CALL YOU A
MURDERER.
LET'S MAKE IT SIMPLE.
WE NEED TO HARDEN SOFT TARGETS.
BIG COMPANIES DO THIS ALREADY.
THEY ARE SURROUNDED BY GUARDS.
SO SHOULD SCHOOLS.
IT'S A TRILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
WAITING TO HAPPEN.
BRING BACK PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS.
THE HOUSE LESS THAN ONE-TENTH OF
THE PEOPLE THEY DID 60 YEARS
AGO.
IF OUR AGENCY LOOK AT THIS
LATEST CREEP IN 2016 BUT THEY
LET HIM GO.
DO YOU WANT TO BET IT WAS BASED
ON SPACE, THAT HE WASN'T WORTH A
BED?
WE MUST -- THE MEDIA FOOTPRINT
OF KILLERS.
CREEPS OBSESS OVER THE FAME OF
PREVIOUS CREEPS.
IT'S THEIR DRUG.
LET'S TAKE AWAY THAT DRUG.
WE NEED TO THINK ALL
OFFENSIVELY.
INSTEAD OF ASKING HOW DO WE RIG
THE SYSTEM TO STOP PERPS FROM
GETTING GUNS.
ASK HOW DO WE TAG THE PURPOSE
AND KEEP THEM FROM GETTING GUNS.
WE WANT TO GET THE BAD EGGS, NOT
THE LAW-ABIDING ONES.
FLORIDA WAS PREVENTABLE.
RED FLAGS, PERFECT FOR A
DATABASE OF THE NUTS AND PERPS
WHO SHOULDN'T GET GUNS.
THIS GUY HAD NO VIOLENT FELONIES
OR CIVIL TAG IS WHAT COULD'VE
NAILED HIM BASED ON TESTIMONY
FROM COPS, STUDENTS, SCHOOL
OFFICIALS, A JUDGE COULD ISSUE A
SIMPLE COURT ORDER.
RATHER THAN DEFECTIVELY CAST A
WIDE NET THAT CATCHES TONS OF
FISH WE DON'T WANT, YOU TAG THE
RIGHT PEOPLE WHO ARE PLACED INTO
ONE SINGLE DATABASE ALONG WITH
VIOLENT FELONS.
IF YOU ARE IN IT, NO GUN.
YOU VIOLATE THE DATABASE, THAT'S
MANDATORY PRISON TIME.
SO THIS ISN'T JUST SEEING
SOMETHING, SAY SOMETHING, IT'S
ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING.
BY ALL MEANS, PROTEST.
BUT IT WON'T DO MUCH WHEN YOU
ARE TARGETING THE HAYSTACK WHILE
LETTING THE NEEDLE SLIP THROUGH.
WE LEARNED ABOUT THE FBI
SCREWUP, KIMBERLY.
NOW ABOUT THIS FLORIDA MENTAL
HEALTH AGENCY, THAT IT EXAMINED
THIS GUY IN 2016 BUT THEY DIDN'T
HOSPITALIZE HIM.
THE ARTICLE I READ DIDN'T SAY
WHY BUT I'M ASSUMING IF THERE
WAS ROOM FOR HIM, WHY NOT HOLD
HIM FOR 72 HOURS.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN DO THAT.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO SOME
ANALYSIS ON THAT, TALK TO THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE, THE SUPERVISOR
ON DUTY, WHO HAD CONTACT WITH
HIM AND MADE THAT DETERMINATION.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING
TO GET BETTER.
UNLESS YOU DO THESE KINDS OF
THOUGHTFUL, DELIBERATE, DEEP
PROBING INVESTIGATIONS.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN DO IT
BETTER FOR THE NEXT TIME BECAUSE
THIS CANNOT CONTINUE TO HAPPEN,
ESPECIALLY WHEN SOMEONE IS
BASICALLY SCREAMING OUT FOR
HELP, PRESENTING THESE PROBLEMS,
HAVING THIS VIOLENT IDEATION,
SAYING THEY WANT TO BECOME A
SCHOOL SHOOTER, THEY HAVE THE
WEAPONS IN AMENABILITY TO DO SO.
THEY GO IN FRONT OF A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL.
THE FBI HAS THEM ON THE SCREEN.
IT WASN'T ON ONE LEVEL THIS WAS
A FAIL, IT WAS MULTIPLE LEVELS
PEOPLE COULD HAVE CAUGHT THIS.
MAYBE 72 HOURS.
>> Greg: SELF HARMING, SNAP
CHATS.
THIS GUY HAS MORE RED FLAGS AND
A RED FLAG FACTORY.
WE TALKED ABOUT VEGAS, I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE COULD HAVE PREVENTED
THAT.
THAT GUY CAPITALIZE ON
OBSCURITY.
NO ONE KNEW.
THIS IS A GUY TELLING YOU WHAT
HE'S GOING TO DO AND NOBODY
LISTENS.
>> Juan: THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER OR NOT YOU TAKE HIM
SERIOUSLY AND HIS CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
WHAT WE KNOW IS GOING BACK TO
THE '80s AND EARLIER, THE DAY
D INSTITUTIONALIZED PEOPLE AND
SAID FOLKS HAVE A RIGHT TO NOT
HAVE THEIR FREEDOMS TAKEN AWAY
BECAUSE YOU DEEM THEM TO BE SOME
HELP MENTALLY INCOMPETENT.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHO YOU ARE
PICKING ON, WHO YOU ARE NOT
PICKING ON.
I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
I THINK IT'S A DANGER,
INCREASING DANGER TO SOCIETY
WHEN YOU HAVE SO MANY NOT ONLY
PEOPLE WHO ARE OF A MURDEROUS
INSTINCT.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE HIGH RATES
OF PEOPLE WHO, FOR EXAMPLE,
VETERANS WHO HAVE TRAUMATIC
SYNDROME AS HOMELESS PEOPLE.
I SEE MORE HOMELESS PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY THAN EVER.
I THINK THAT'S A LOT OF MENTAL
ILLNESS.
I WILL SAY IT'S GREAT THE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO MARCH IN
WASHINGTON.
I THINK HOPEFULLY IT WILL CHANGE
THE TENOR OF THE DEBATE.
MAYBE IF YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SAYING
YOU'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING, IT
WILL APPEAL TO PEOPLE WHO, AS
YOU POINT OUTCOME ARE LOCKED
INTO OWN, YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE
MY GUNS.
GUN OWNERS, NRA MEMBERS THINK
BACKGROUND CHECKS CAN BE DONE
BETTER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID TODAY,
OR HIS AIDES OF SAID, HE IS
INTERESTED IN DOING SOMETHING TO
STRENGTHEN THE BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
>> Greg: THESE SUGGESTIONS I
MADE, I THINK DAVID FRENCH WROTE
A GOOD PIECE FOR NATIONAL REVIEW
ON --
>> Dana: GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
>> Greg: FROM THE CONSERVATIVE
LIBERTARIAN SIDE.
NO ONE TRUSTED COMING FROM THE
OTHER SIDE BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS
SO -- WE HEAR THE DOG WHISTLE
THAT THEY ARE COMING TO THE GUNS
AWAY.
>> Jesse: IT IS TRUE.
A PRE9/11 MIND-SET WHEN IT COMES
TO SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
AFTER 9/11, EVERYONE REALIZED
THEY WERE -- THE AGENCIES
WEREN'T SHARING ANYTHING WITH
EACH OTHER.
AND I HAVE THE POLICE, SCHOOL,
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY.
EVERYBODY KNOWS SOMETHING, EVEN
THE FBI, NO ONE IS SHARING THIS
INFORMATION.
YOU LOOK AT A THREAT MATRIX ON A
KID LIKE THIS.
HE'S DIAGNOSED AUTISTIC,
DEPRESSED, MENTALLY UNSTABLE BY
THE AGENCY THAT LOOKED AT HIM
AND SOMEONE WHO IS AN AT RISK
ADULTS BECAUSE OF MENTAL
INSTABILITY.
HE WAS DEVELOP MENTALLY
DISABLED.
YOU HAVE A MOBILE CRISIS UNIT
DISPATCHED TO THE SCHOOL.
HE'S EXPELLED FOR VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR AT THE SCHOOL.
THE POLICE ARE CALLED DOZENS OF
TIMES TO THE HOUSE.
IF YOU ADD THAT UP, ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT THINGS, YOU SAY IF
SOMEONE QUALIFIES FOR 60% OF ALL
THOSE THINGS, THEN MAYBE THEY
DON'T GET A GUN.
MAYBE YOU MAKE THEM WAIT A FEW
YEARS BEFORE HE'S ABLE TO
PURCHASE A WEAPON LIKE THAT AT
THAT AGE.
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED GUN CONTROL
BUT IT WOULDN'T BE TAKING GUNS
AWAY FROM PEOPLE.
OR NOT MANUFACTURING THE HOUR
15.
CAN'T EVEN BAND BUMP STOCKS
AFTER VEGAS.
BUT WE SHOULD DO THESE
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND MAKE SURE
THE INFORMATION SHARED
APPROPRIATELY.
>> Greg: WHENEVER GUN CONTROL,
THE LAW-ABIDING GUN OWNER THINKS
IT'S ABOUT THEM.
THE IDEA IS TO SWITCH IT.
NO, IT'S MOST LIKE STOP AND
FRISK CORPORATION COMMUNITY
POLICING APPLIED TO THIS.
>> Dana: I THINK SO AND I
THINK IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A
CONGRESSIONAL MOVE HERE.
STATES ARE THE POLICY
INNOVATORS.
THIS IS MOSTLY ESTATES -- STATE
RIGHT ISSUE.
YOU COULD DO THAT IN
TALLAHASSEE.
THAT COULD HAPPEN IN FLORIDA.
OR YOU MIGHT DO IT IN ANOTHER
STATE AND IT'S AN EXPERIMENT.
THAT'S WHERE THE EXPERIENCE
THAT'S WHERE THE EXPERIENCE    E
THAT'S WHERE THE EXPERIENCE    P
THAT'S WHERE THE EXPERIENCE    R
THAT'S WHERE THE EXPERIENCE    M
THAT'S WHERE THE EXPERIENCE    N
THAT'S WHERE THE EXPERIENCE    S
HAPPENS, IN THE STATES.
SOMETIMES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL DO THINGS LIKE
TYPE TRANSPORTATION FUNDS IN
ORDER TO GET A STATE TO COMPLY
WITH SOMETHING LIKE THE DRINKING
AGE OR SOMETHING.
IF THIS WERE TO WORK IN A
CERTAIN PLACE, YOU COULD TRY IT
OUT SOMEWHERE.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY LIKE THE
MOTHER FROM CONNECTICUT AT
SANDY HOOK.
SHE TRIED TO GET HELP.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO GO.
THERE'S REAL CONCERN ABOUT CUTS
TO MEDICAID WHICH IS WHERE A LOT
OF PEOPLE GET THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH HELP IF THEY ARE GOING TO
GET ANY.
I HADN'T HEARD THE AUTISM
DIAGNOSIS.
I THINK -- I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT IT.
THERE IS A TENDENCY TO
EXTRAPOLATE THAT INTO OTHERS.
I WOULD SAY ON THE COMMUNICATION
STANDPOINT, THE KIDS STAYING IN
THIS STORY MAKES IT VERY HARD
FOR THE MEDIA TO IGNORE IT.
THEY KNOW THAT.
I THINK THEY'VE BEEN PRETTY
SMART.
THEY ARE WORKING TOGETHER, USING
SOCIAL NETWORKS IN ORDER TO
GATHER NOT JUST IN TALLAHASSEE.
THEY ARE CALLING FOR A MARCH ON
MARCH 24.
THAT SOUNDS WEIRD.
A MARCH IN MARCH.
MARCH 24.
THE MORE THEY STAY IN THE STORY,
IT'S HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO IGNORE
BUT I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK
THIS IS JUST A CONGRESSIONAL
ISSUE.
I THINK YOU CAN GET MORE DONE
FASTER AT THE STATE LEVEL.
>> Greg: I THINK THE MEDIA
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE -- THIS IS A
HIGHLY VISUAL PROTEST,
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S GOING TO BE
NATIONWIDE AND THE WOMEN'S MARCH
IS GOING TO GET BEHIND IT WHICH
IS GOING TO RAISE SUSPICIONS
THAT IT'S A POLITICAL EVENT AND
A LIBERAL ONE.
THAT'S AN ERROR.
AND AN ERROR TO DOC ABOUT
REPEALING THE SECOND AMENDMENT
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
BUT YOU HEAR THAT.
I THINK THE MEDIA MAY BE FOCUSED
WHY HE WASN'T PLACED IN THE
HOSPITAL.
HOW DID THE FBI DROPPED THE BALL
AS WELL AS THESE PROTESTS.
>> Kimberly: YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S NOT GOING TO BE A
DIRECT, FULL ON ASSAULT ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
GIVEN THE POLITICAL DIFFERENCES
AND IDEOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES, TO
TRY TO USE THIS AS A VEHICLE TO
TRY TO CONFISCATE GUNS.
THERE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE
SOMEBODY CAN JUST MAKE A
COMPLAINT AGAINST YOUR NEIGHBOR
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL.
>> Dana: IT WILL BE LIKE ONCE
YOU GET ON THE LIST, HOW WOULD
YOU -- IN ORDER TO GET OFF OF IT
YOU -- IN ORDER TO GET OFF OF I
IT.
I THINK ONE OF THE STATES COULD
START THIS.
>> Greg: IF IT'S A CIVIL TAG,
THAT MEANS THE BARS LOWER.
IT'S ABOUT THESE PEOPLE.
IT'S ABOUT THE GUY YOU KNOW.
IT'S LIKE NOBODY KNOWS WHAT TO
DO WITH THE PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: KIMBERLY MENTIONED
THAT A STATE AGENCY VISITED THIS
GUY AFTER HE WAS POSTING
PICTURES ON SOCIAL MEDIA OF HIM
CUTTING HIMSELF AND SAYING HE
WANTED TO DO VIOLENCE AND BUY A
GUN.
HE WAS WEARING LONG SLEEVES OF
THE TIME AND THE REASON THEY
DIDN'T COMMIT HIM WAS BECAUSE
THEY NEVER CHECKED AND LOOKED AT
HIS SLEEVES.
PULL YOUR SLEEVES UP.
PATHETIC VISIT BY THAT STATE
AGENCY.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS.
THEY ARE PRESSED AND THEY HAVE
SO MANY OCCASIONS AND THEY DO A
RUSH.
I WON'T EVEN TELL YOU.
THEY DIDN'T CHECK A LITTLE GIRL
HAD BEEN BEATEN.
HER SCALLOPED WAS DUCT TAPED.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU BROUGHT UP
VETS.
>> WHEN 9/11 HAPPENED, THE
PLANES HIT THE TOWERS, AIRPORTS
WERE CHANGED FOREVER.
WE GOT THE TSA.
OUR CHILDREN ARE GETTING HIT.
IT'S TIME TO CHANGE THE SCHOOLS
FOREVER.
THERE'S A POPULATION OF THERE.
I DIDN'T HAVE A NEW STANCE BUT
LAST YEAR'S STATS FOR .3%
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR RETURNING VETS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
435,000 TRAINED MEN WHO HAVE
EYES AND EARS.
WE NEED TO HAVE THEM AT THE
SCHOOLS.
>> Greg: I THINK IT'S A GREAT
IDEA.
>> Juan: THE CRITICISM IS IF
YOU POLICE THE SCHOOLS SO
INTENSELY, THEN EVERYTHING A
YOUNG PERSON DOES BECOMES A
CRIMINAL ACT RATHER THAN A
TEENAGER ACTING UP.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, NOW THERE'S A
CRIMINAL RECORD.
ESSENTIALLY YOU ARE
INSTITUTIONALIZING A SCHOOL IN A
WAY THAT I DON'T THINK SCHOOLS
ARE INTENDED.
>> Dana: IF I UNDERSTAND WHAT
TYRUS IS SAYING, THEY WOULDN'T
BE THERE IN ORDER TO HAVE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION OVERSIGHT.
THEY WOULD BE THERE TO PROTECT.
>> Juan: THAT WOULD BE IDEAL
BOAT IF YOU HAVE POLICE THERE,
THEN I THINK THE SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES --
>> Dana: THE VETS WOULDN'T BE
POLICE.
>> Juan: THE BIGGER POINT IS
BASICALLY PEOPLE GET LOCKED IN
TO THEIR POLITICAL BOXES RIGHT
HERE.
PEOPLE WILL SAY YOU'RE COMING
FROM MY GUNS.
TO MY MIND, WHEN I THINK ABOUT
THE NRA AND ITS ROLE HERE, I
DON'T SEE HOW YOU GET AWAY FROM
IT BECAUSE THEY ARE SO HEAVILY
POLITICIZED AND THEY PUT SO MANY
DOLLARS INTO REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES.
THEY BACKED REPUBLICANS.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE NRA
INFLUENCE IS A LITTLE OVERRATED.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD PUTS A LOT
MORE MONEY.
IF ANY PRESIDENT COULD DO
SOMETHING ON THIS ISSUE, I THINK
DONALD TRUMP GOOD.
VERY, VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AND IF HE WANTS
TO GIVE A LITTLE ON BACKGROUND
CHECKS COME I THINK THE COUNTRY
WOULD BE OPEN TO IT.
>> Juan: ABSOLUTELY.
THE QUESTION IS WOULD HIS RIGHT
WING BE OPEN TO IT.
WITH THE NRA BE OPEN TO IT?
I THINK SO MANY OF THE CASE OF
GUN OWNERS ARE SINGLE ISSUE
VOTERS, AND THAT'S THE ONLY
ISSUE.
THEY SEE THE WHOLE WORLD THROUGH
THAT PRISM AND ARE EASILY
THREATENED.
I THINK IF TRUMP, OTHERS AT THE
NRA WOULD SAY LISTEN, HERE'S A
REASONABLE STEP WE CAN GET
BEHIND, IT WOULD MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE REMEMBER, WE
DIDN'T GET BUMP STOCKS.
WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY ADDED STEPS
IN TERMS OF THE MENTAL ILLNESS
ISSUE THAT GREG IS TALKING ABOUT
TODAY.
MEDICARE, AS DANA WAS TALKING
ABOUT, LESS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COVERAGE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
TO ME, THIS IS STARING US IN THE
FACE.
WE DON'T NEED TO WONDER ABOUT
IT.
>> Greg: WE HAVEN'T HAD GOOD,
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS FROM THE
LOUDEST VOICES.
THE ACLU CAME OUT AGAINST THE
OBAMA BILL BECAUSE IT WAS A
DEFENSIVE MOVE, CASTING A WIDE
NET ON PEOPLE WHO CAN'T FILL OUT